[Music]
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see i was dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming undone
grindelwald's pulling it apart with hate
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
a major zoologist his indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
a school teacher
[Music]
and
a muggle dumbledore said i give you
something
are you kidding me right now who
wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
swivel but delicately i'm swiveling
right you're traveling
our wall with the knuckles
[Music]
begin
okay
what is this place the room we require
[Music]
correct three points to hufflepuff
very dangerous forgotten wrong hands
mess you up where did you guess it
i got for christmas